[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
wazières ravi de vous retrouver pour
cette édition spéciale halloween tout de
suite le sommaire de ce jeudi 25 octobre
france miniature a besoin de vous pour
retrouver les ingrédients de la potion
maléfique pour les vacances le parc une
animation spéciale halloween
marionnettes venir sera avec nous pour
reparler pour jouer les sorties autour
d'une marmite vous avons rencontré un
artisan siro pied de chevreuse et nous
apprend à faire un sirop potiron et
épices et halloween c'est aussi des
films d'horreur l'association soute la
organise une soirée spéciale à voisins
le bretonneux du film d'animation coup
flash movie il y en aura pour toute la
famille un sort a été jeté sur le parc
de france miniature pendant les vacances
les ingrédients de la potion maléfique
se cachent dans les monuments avec nous
en plateau marianne et 10 rebonds jours
bonjour alors vous êtes responsable
communication du parc donc la déco des
énigmes à résoudre et des bonbons il
veut une petit berger s'y est rendu pour
voir ce que les familles on pense qu'on
va regarder fait au dessus il y avait
aussi des jambes qui sortait du sol
bizarrement et les citrouilles en fait
elle avait une tête
qu'ils aient peur c'était trop bien en
fait il y avait des pièges et et c'était
des citrouilles et hey hey hey hey hey
du coup pas ils disaient que c'étaient
des pinèdes tu devais chercher des
indices de file du corps comme des
licornes voilà et après tu gagner plein
de cadeaux vraiment adoré y avait plein
de de bonbons de toutes les couleurs une
sorcière très gentille je crois que tout
le monde s'est bien régalés le fait
d'avoir un jeu c'est vachement
interactif ce qui fait qu'ils regardent
un peu plus les choses et on prend plus
notre temps
moi j'ai très bien née parce que je me
suis beaucoup amusé à ignorer s'il me
tue fait des copains cette fois c'est
d'être cool alors on peut voir que les
enfants et se prennent au jeu qu'est ce
qu'il doit faire exactement alors à
france miniature pendant les vacances de
la toussaint on remet à tous nos
visiteurs un petit livret de jeux une
petite feuille de jeu qui leur permet de
partir à la recherche de cinq indices
cachés dans les maquettes pour composer
une potion est présenté cette motion à
la sorcière qui les accueillera avec
cette potion en échange de cette potion
on pourra leur remettre des confiseries
en général c'est vraiment la clé de ces
de ces énigmes les petits bonbons mais
on se rend compte que ce qui plaît
surtout aux enfants et aux parents c'est
de s'amuser sur le parc à la recherche
de ces indices donc il y aura des
personnages pour les aider il ya des
personnages hauts en couleurs qui sont
là pour les accompagner et les aiguilles
et d
des personnages qui sont perchés sur
échasses on a vraiment joué le grand
petit à france miniature
il ya un dragon par exemple qui se
promène il ya une sorcière qui
représente la mort c'est une mort qui
n'attrape pas grand monde chez nous mais
elle est là quand même
et puis on a une gargouille qui rebondit
sur des échasses rebondissantes qui elle
est beaucoup plus le gai luron de cette
de cette aventure en se promenant dans
le para one ces personnages qui parfois
raconte des histoires il ya peu un
aspect spectacles de rue aussi c'est ça
on est vraiment sûr du spectacle de rue
des activités de cirque
il ya des petites animations autour du
feu aussi puisque ses animateurs
ponctuellement se positionne dans
différents endroits du parc pour jongler
ou faire des déambulations avec du feu
il ya une sorcière qui maquille les
enfants aussi avec d'une très jolie une
très jolie plume et puis qui récompense
du coup tout ce qu'ils ont trouvé la
potion magique pendant leur balade donc
on a vu dans le micro trottoir là les
les parents ils pointent aussi l'aspect
ludique pour les enfants et qui
s'intéressent un peu plus au monument
vous l'avez constaté aussi oui tout à
fait on se rend compte que quand on leur
indique un parcours à suivre avec à la
clé des recherches
et puis des focus particulier sur les
monuments les enfants se prêtent
beaucoup au jeu donc ils ont une corde
de licorne a retrouvé ils ont une petite
chauve-souris qui est caché dans un
célèbre monument dans au plein milieu de
l'atlantique
ils ont une fiole avec de la bave de
crapaud à récupérer également
et tous ces petits indices la faune
qu'effectivement ça ajoute du piment à
la visite et donc ça s'adressait à tout
le monde on n'est pas trop petit pas
trop grand c'est vraiment tout public
puisque on est vraiment sur un jeu
d'observation donc si tout le monde ne
sait pas lire dans la famille on a
toujours un pour aiguiller sur la petite
question
on est vraiment tous publics grands
parents parents petits enfants et on
propose à nos visiteurs de venir nous
rejoindre encore dimanche et mercredi 31
octobre pour profiter de ces animations
alors il va falloir se couvrir pour
l'instant on a de la chance le soleil
est avec nous il devrait rester mais
même si les températures baissent
enoh intermittents du spectacle seront
là jusqu'au 31 octobre
ea pour se mettre aux couleurs on peut
venir déguisé on peut venir déguisés ça
ajoute de la couleur au parc et ça met
un petit peu de piment à l aventure
avant de se quitter un petit pot un
petit mot sur le pare donc c'est que
c'est 5 hectares en tout avec 117
monument reproduit c'est un lieu unique
en france
c'est un lieu unique puisque c'est le
seul endroit effectivement ou dans la
même journée vous pouvez être tantôt à
saint tropez tantôt mont saint michel ou
encore à strasbourg on se promène dans
le parc et en quelques enjambées
on parcourt vraiment toute la carte de
france donc france miniature ses 117
monument il ya une quinzaine
d'expériences interactives où on propose
à nos visiteurs de de jouer avec le
décor on peut faire sonner des cloches
dans les alpes on peut essayer doté
escalibur du rocher du roi arthur dans
la forêt de brocéliande
on a vraiment différents lieux où on
propose à nos visiteurs de découvrir la
france ces régions en s'amusant et vous
le disiez de salaire c'est le moment
d'en profiter avant la fermeture
hivernale
en effet on fermera les portes pour
l'hiver le 4 novembre au soir à la fin
des vacances scolaires pour redonner un
petit coup de neuf au parc pendant
l'hiver et puis pour mettre au chaud les
objets et les monuments qui en auraient
besoin
et puis on donnera rendez vous à nos
visiteurs au printemps prochain très
bien merci ray marianne et de l'ird est
venu sur notre plateau halloween à
france miniature c'est les après midi
dès dimanche 28 et mercredi 31 octobre
au tarif habituel du parc et pour fêter
halloween chez soi je vous propose
d'apprendre à faire votre propre siro
potiron et épices pour cela nous nous
sommes rendus chez l'alchimiste un
artisan cyr opté de chevreuse des images
de man par aldo marque chenu d'artisans
siro pied depuis 2015 il s'est installé
ici à chevreuse où il propose une
soixantaine de sirop pour halo unis va
nous apprendre à en faire un pour dire
on est aux épices
il
[Musique]
à
bark vous allez nous présenter un sirop
saveur un peu d'allant minuit tout à
fait avec donc qu'on m'appelait potiron
aux épices mais c'est un ces deux-là
potter note que je travaillais dans
lequel j'ai rajouté quelques épices là
par étapes ceux qui ont déjà des coupes
et 7 d'internet
une fois qu'elle sera découpée je la met
à vivre pour ramollir atlassian la mixer
et ensuite je fais le travail avec le
sucre et les épices donc réfléchir au
nom montrez moi ça alors là la bonne
terre natale a été rachetée sur combien
vous rajoutez alors je sais à quelle
autre pour un litre de jus bon là
gimmick 3 litres d'eau plus l internet
donc il faut 3 kg de sucre
[Musique]
pensez à ajouter du citron pour aider à
la conservation du sirop munissez-vous
ensuite d'un réfractomètre pour mesurer
le taux de sucre n'hésitez pas à
multiplier les tentatives en rajoutant
du sucre petit à petit pour atteindre
les 55 %
ajoutez ensuite votre cannelle petites
astuces de marque venus privilégier une
canne alan b plus riches en arômes et
plus facile à travailler donc là ça y
est la plaque
donc je vais pouvoir l'intégrer alors
pour intégrer de la cannelle une épice
dans un sirop je vais y aller avec
parcimonie
parce que si je mets tout d'un coup ça
est-ce que d'être une dominante cannes l
espace de recherche
[Musique]
ça y est maintenant plus que la dernière
étape la pasteurisation pour la
conservation
on a notre sirop avec de la boîte aux
lettres et de la cannelle alors à quoi
il peut vous servir comme on peut le
déguster brosse à dents des thés noirs
au lieu de mettre du sud bolt et ceux ci
ou ça sa feinte et gourmand on peut
mettre ça sur des fréquences en effet
celle c'est très agréable
depuis sous les 1 pour plusieurs
originalités vous mettez à jonas à
l'avenir et ce avant un petit côté
châtaignes en plus l'association soudja
vous donne rendez-vous dans la tour de
la terreur cette association qui a des
lycéens cinéphiles a préparé une option
cinéma au baccalauréat organise une
soirée spéciale une projection de trois
films d'horreur accompagné d'une analyse
filmique le samedi 27 octobre à partir
de 17 heures 30 la salle de la torah
voisins le bretonneux sera décorée pour
l'occasion une buvette proposera
boissons début bon peut-être francine
vanille 2 est projeté parce qu'il ya au
théâtre en semaine 3 qui est sorti mon
projet de les chroniques de spiderwick
parce que lui c'est un petit film très
sympathique qui ressent un petit peu si
larry potter dans ces trucs là donc les
enfants les ados la famille 7 peut
assister à ce genre de film et on a
choisi donc halloween la nuit des
masques qui est le premier film sorti en
1979 de john carpenter et de la série
donc halloween
parce que cette année le dernier
halloween va sortir avec jamie lee
curtis et tous les acteurs de l'époque
il ya des explications analyse filmique
qui sont derrière aussi pour montrer
qu'on est là qu'on fait du cinéma pour
qu'on en arrive à la
il faut qu'on arrive à une soirée film
sur le thème d'halloween
l'entrée est gratuite il est conseillé
d'envoyer un mail à l'association pour
réserver après les cowboys et les
indiens la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet lance un défi aux enfants
faire ses preuves pour intégrer l'école
des sorciers désagréments chanteur de la
bergerie nous avons suivi les honore
mails qui ont tenté leur chance
pendant les vacances les honore et maël
sont venus récupérer leurs grimoire à la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet ils
vont jusqu'à 16h30 pour résoudre les
énigmes
on a pris un thème qui s'appelle sait
pas que sorciers avec l'idée de faire un
mix entre des choses qui peuvent sembler
un peu magique et des choses qu'on va
expliquer de façon un peu scientifique
gratter le ballon avec de la laine pour
avoir en tout mais s'il ya quelque chose
mais là ya donc quelques minutes le
frère et la soeur maîtrise le sort de
lévitation
il parvient à déchiffrer le code qui se
cacher sous les feuilles d'aluminium
après au mont-dore direction sabots tard
pour retrouver les caractéristiques des
équidés magique
les apprentis sorciers ont réussi à
maîtriser le cheval noir
il faut désormais regarder le plan pour
se rendre dans les classes de verre de
lait après les sortilèges et la théorie
des animaux fantastiques place aux
potions un bon sorcier doit savoir
reconnaître une composants une fois la
liste des ingrédients trouvés ils
apprennent à maîtriser plume et encre
invisible chesser de coque avant de se
rendre à dernière épreuve des chiffres
est le secret de l'arbre est un e
reste souffrir un chemin 500
participants ont tenté leur chance ce
jour là c'est une très bonne activité
ludique qui se sont bien amusés sont
bien pris au jeu et puis bon ben là
c'est des sorciers ils vont aller voir
les ils vont prendre le temps d'aller
voir les animaux les honorer ma elles
n'ont plus qu'à se procurer robe de
sorcier et baguette magique pour faire
leur nouvelle rentrée dans le monde des
sorciers et de nombreuses autres
animations sont proposées pour halloween
à saint quentin en yvelines
la citrouille le plus célèbre des
cucurbitacées du 31 octobre sera gris
mais les fermes de gally lui font ça
fait ainsi que la ferme pédagogique de
l'île de loisirs pensez à réserver pour
pouvoir décorer votre légumes
d'halloween
plusieurs jeux sont à découvrir dans
l'agglomération et à versailles les
jardins du potager du roi ouvrent leurs
voûtes et souterrains et vous font
découvrir plus de 30 variétés de courges
pour les gourmands avides de mystère le
restaurant théâtre rémy naissance vous
invite à une murder party déguster un
menu spécial tout en essayant de
résoudre une enquête pour savoir qui a
tué le stage les clayes-sous-bois
organise trois jours d'activités pour
les familles
moment phare le 31 octobre avec une
soirée déguisée à l'espace philippe
noiret de 21h à minuit
nouveauté cette année la ville prépare
un spectacle de flamme n'est de
paillettes avec son la fondation mandela
à 20 heures et pour éliminer les bonbons
le très lourd in revient de course de 19
et 10 km aux clayes-sous-bois le départ
est prévu à 9 heures au parc jean
carillon 1 euro par inscription sera
reversée à l'association imagine fort
margot et c'est la fin de votre 7,8
choisi hier j'espère que vous avoir
donné des idées pour bien fonctionner le
31 octobre pas d'édition la semaine
prochaine je vous rendez je vous donne
rendez vous la semaine suivante pour un
yb etienne numéro
non
ouais
oh
[Musique]